DC Comics al Ghul has the most
impractical living space of all time
unless there's some sort of hidden road
on the backside there isn't even a way
to get up here I don't even see a place
to land my helicopter I should never
have allied myself with a madman Rachele
Ghul instigates dropping a full glass of
wine after hearing something shocking
cliche prior to being told by his
assistant that the Joker's kidnapped
Robin also not sure what al Ghul's plan
is here but it's the fucking Joker of
course he's gonna kidnap and torture
Robin or who remember he can get his
hands off if he wanted a less mad and
senior partner he should have gone for
the condiment King or kite man nitrus
did Batman really go to the fast and
furious school of accelerating things
what hurts more I'm not completely clear
on the exact powers of Boy Wonder bread
here but he's invincibility one of them
cuz dude just took a crowbar to the face
repeatedly in is somehow still breathing
for all the blood that's on the floor
there is surprisingly none on Robins
face please tell the big man I said
hello other than newbies got a red hood
it makes zero sense that the Joker would
leave Robin alive and give him a chance
to escape before the bomb goes off not
the best Joker laugh I've ever heard
sounds like he's coming off a three-day
bender how did the masked air in that
spot without doing any damage to the
surrounding face in fact the opposite
eye seems to be the only thing that was
affected by all the crowbars Finnegan's
man even after an explosion Robin still
has flawless skin
you should have forgotten that whole
Supergirl gig and made millions off his
skincare secrets I enjoy stylized rainy
Gotham scenes as much as the next guy
but did you really need to take two full
minutes of a 75 minute movie to do
titles only no wonder Gotha has such a
crime problem the police department is
wasting all of its money on dirigibles I
thought it was Suchi was in my meet
Batman has an insane number of rogues at
this point and just about every name in
the book has been used we couldn't do
better than chichi
not to mention that was already a fairly
important female character from the
animated series named chichi so why not
piss off all the bat maniacs while
you're at it movie well we all know
that's a lie oh and a Deadpool get here
peddling scumbag number seven we'll be
on to something here except for some
unexplained reason none of these armed
hardened criminals actually fired back
when fired upon I will be running the
drug trade from now on you go about your
business as usual but
kick up 40% to me this works those are
the heads of all your lieutenants that
took me two hours and it was made into a
movie with Joe Pesci and the first Buffy
the Vampire Slayer 40% works for me
but how do they get it to him Red Hood
has the negotiation portion down pat but
needs to work a little harder on the
logistics side of his LLC I think I lost
him you think I lost them I think you
lost him no you didn't but if you keep
repeating every line of dialogue three
times you've definitely lost me okay I'm
willing to buy that maybe the back door
will come open but how do you not have
the only thing in your escape truck
secured in any way at least splurge a
few bucks on some bungees Batman is
addictive phalanges I guess this
superhuman Android thing will is
scheduled to hatch out of this metal box
right now nobody punched a code into
this thing why hire a crew to steal it
if the contents were going to escape
before they got halfway back it's called
a maze oh I know it's from the comics
but Amazo
what's next awesome you need Oh ghoulia
oh wait what the hell is an amazing a
highly advanced cybernetic Android
equipped with the ability to absorb the
power of superhumans that's planning
also that is a very specific description
pretty sure Batman gets all his info on
his wiki fandom page just like we do
packs quite the punch for a toaster on
steroids huh in 12 minutes we've had
racial ghoul Joker Jason Todd Robin Red
Hood Amazo and Nightwing all pop up with
little to no explanation not sure why
anyone was surprised how DC backed their
asses into the Justice League movie
they've been pulling this for years
that's Nightwing he was the bats first
sidekick the first Robin I see that this
Robin crew employs a DC nerd on their
staff who knows all things Robin I think
you'll have to do better than that boss
I did why didn't Batman just leave with
this why does this seem to be a common
theme in comic book movies I have this
thing that can end the battle quickly
but now I'll just punch the guy a bunch
first and see if that works
yes the same weak points as a human
being so Oreos and pornography them
lasers he's got lasers
Nightwing is the equivalent of The
Annoying theatre patron who describes
loudly and in excruciating detail
everything that happens on the screen
I don't think putty in his eyes is gonna
hurt him Jesus Christ Nightwing don't
you know your friendly neighborhood
Batman by now this isn't just putty
that's wrong with you it's like you've
never worked with Batman before we don't
have any choice did Red Hood purposely
wait to shoot his crew so they could
almost tell Batman everything the shots
came from the rooftop a sniper you think
honestly is one of Nightwing superhero
aliases Captain Obvious I'm sure all of
these indistinguishable windows on this
display are giving important information
but how in the world is anyone reading
any of this text couple making out on
rooftop gives Batman bad ideas later in
The Killing Joke movie Batman somehow
jumps through the roof in the one spot
he won't land in a vat of acid also do
all villains have these acid VAT
warehouses spread throughout the city I
never actually used the acid for
anything so what caused it they're hard
to forget that night huh it's harder to
believe that Red Hood witnessed what
Batman was flashing back to in his mind
zooming Red Hood was shooting the car to
cause an explosion that would kill
Batman then why didn't Red Hood just
shoot Batman this is probably what the
15th or 16th building to explode in
Gotham in the past month insurance
premiums must be insane State Farm and
Gotham's construction companies are
taking everyone's money Red Hood has
done it all including just basic
trafficking what was he trafficking does
it matter we cut that asshole Red Hood
it crime is down indeed it is
master Bruce got almost three hours
sleep in the last two days true busman's
holiday the percentage of the audience
watching this that know what this means
corresponds directly to the percentage
of things kanye west says that are fat
crazy also Alfred's technically wrong
here a busman's holiday is meant to
refer to people who keep working when on
vacation while Batman is literally doing
his job wait Batman and Nightwing can
just walk out that door themselves with
no guards in sight seems like pretty
slim security when you have Gotham's
number-one mastermind on the other side
of that door this here is the black mask
the first boss to gain control of the
entire city in 20 years
steer bat guard and bat heaven is this
whole movie just blatant exposition
here's five sins so I don't have to keep
bringing it up every time a random
character over explains who someone is
or why it's important why does Batman
have to make everything with his
personal stamp on it wouldn't it be
easier to just buy a 20 pack of small
Mike's on Amazon does he trademark
English and making money off of it also
Batman is successfully bugged black
mask's office and while this is great
and all why doesn't Batman just take him
down
if you don't was where the biggest
criminal in the entire city does
business why can't he just end it was he
scared of due process
seriously
waiting around dude literally started
walking over the moment you landed these
random helicopter pilots are more
impatient than DC trying to develop a
cinematic universe so since none of
these characters have actual superpowers
and that fall would kill everyone
involved I can only assume that these
three are zombies for the rest of the
runtime I'm wondering something if Red
Hood doesn't want to kill Batman so that
he can teach him a lesson later how come
he keeps doing things that could
possibly kill Batman and if he wants to
kill Batman he had a perfectly good
sniper shot to do that earlier when he
killed those poor bastards who were
about to tell Batman about him random
and convenient blimp is random and
convenient we got him Nightwing you're
such an asshole
that's impressive nothing we haven't
seen before exactly so why does
Nightwing up a Red Hood boner going on
right now when he and Batman do this
exact same nightly where exactly is this
footage coming from even if it was in
Batman's hood and he was behind Red Hood
at this point it wouldn't be this steady
because Batman will be running as well
as much as I hate to belabor a point and
still it is often exactly what to do oh
it would be exemplary at cinema since
I'm chatty it's part of my charm
so we're just blatantly ripping off
spider-man at this point like right
there that he sliced that cable off his
ankle before it went taut you don't just
do that that has to be practiced learn
you know at cable slicing before it goes
taut school I have an online course but
to get the real benefits you need to
train in Hong Kong under doctor whooping
for two years you know many knives that
can cut my lines not many no not many
are we repeating us in for repeatedly
repeating lines yes we are repeating us
in for repeatedly repeating lines even
when Robin was what age is this ten I
guess whatever he already trained super
hard on that cable slicing before it
goes taut program this kind of thing
happens more than you think apparently
oh come on who shoots at the top of a
doorway the stupid-ass move by Robin his
stupid ass and the problem is he
survives it encouraging him to do it
again and that's results-oriented
thinking that should end in his death
sooner or later 20 rounds a second and
you were still too slow I'm not so Punk
first off being slow wasn't the machine
gun guy's problem
it was his aim second off if you tell
someone that you're about to kill I'm
not too slow then you were officially
too slow also I had to take him down you
shattered his collarbone he is Batman
really trying to give lessons on not
hurting
if I see thy name is Bruce where did
this cape come from because when we
started this trip down memory lane there
were as Edna mode would say not text
Molotov cocktail I swear - these aren't
lightsaber rip offs we call them Chloe
blades discount Cyclops somehow weights
this long and the fight to do the only
thing it was brought here to do today
was bat mocking her I gotta say I missed
watching you work
oh we're just not even trying to hide
identities at this point I even keep the
red hood on of the Batman no one else
would know who Jason Todd is black mass
just wants a body we don't need your
head actually it didn't black mask imply
he did nail me and you'll electrocute
both of us sure we've been given the bat
crumbs to know that this is Robin but
why would anyone else think Batman cares
about hurting the Red Hook son are you
telling me that scumbag stole my guns
again black mask seems to have no other
purpose than to Yosemite Sam it up as
much as possible we've stuck in the damn
crossfire why does Red Hood a meet a
bazooka to kill black mask B need a red
dot to aim this thing C wave to black
mask and give him a head start and D
weight in additional 13 seconds before
firing also what kind of black magic is
he using to see this laser target have
you ever tried to look at your neck go
ahead give it a whirl
exactly you didn't have to kill him one
yes I did
- we're paying you a ton three we need
some more Joker in the movie so we're
pretending breaking him out is as simple
as paying off a couple guards also there
are so many escape attempts at Arkham
Asylum it's all under Batman doesn't
have this place constantly surveilled
grave robbing these are supposed to be
potato chips right this chip looks more
like an onion ring here as we clearly
see the Joker's finger and prison garb
through it may I have some water
you mean milk that's definitely milk I
was in the midst of toppling the economy
of Europe but you were on to me this is
the beginning of an entire five minutes
of narrated flashback I mean there's
exposition and then there's being
tricked into thinking you're watching an
animated film when you're actually just
listening to a book on tape Batman who
we've been told time after time in these
movies is one step ahead of everybody is
amazing and knows all is somehow
surprised by a two-bit Joker henchman
and is dropped by one punch so that this
death no family can happen as you know I
achieve this by bathing the rejuvenating
waters of the Lazarus Pit as you know
any time a character says as you know I
yell at the screen and why are you
telling them I'm fun
also the Lazarus Pit is essentially DC's
ultimate death machina therefore there
are rarely any stakes because you can
just go to Rachel's place and get your
life back it has long been rumored that
it is capable of an even greater feat to
raise the dead it's called the Lazarus
Pit I'm guessing that's for a reason he
burns their very kingdom you protect the
story was so long even Batman checked
out his life and his death are my
greatest failure do you remember how he
was when I found him haven't we already
gone over this a few times were way too
many minutes wasted on moody morning
Batman in this movie glad to see Gotham
employing a multi Zeppelin attack during
this Joker diversion
how did nobody know until now the city's
most dangerous criminal had escaped
Arkham Asylum I mean they should have
some sort of tracker on this guy at this
point don't you think
why is he repeating the same thing he
said earlier here more flashy matre D
than motorcycle fetish it was barely
funny the first time is repeating it's
supposed to be clever but what I really
wanted was an audience I'm sorry that
seems to imply that you organized this
little clambake it most definitely does
which makes zero sense
even if red hoods eventual plan was to
get the Joker broken out so he could
kill him how did he know black masks
would eventually be the one to break him
out here's to warm memories later
finally lightning after trying several
times while the killer says something
crazy a metaphorical cliche I get that
it landed on a person instead of the
actual gasoline but as stringent as that
area was that entire truck would have
gone up in flames
instantly either way seriously the
batplane has fire retardant its plane is
so thin how does he have room for this
also let's say Batman had Richard
Dreyfuss ghost guiding him and he was
actually good enough to make that shot
there's still no way enough of that
stuff is getting in there to put out
that fire in fact because it's in motion
most of what got in there would end up
on the back wall anyway Batman has pink
foam that will shoot out of his jet if
he randomly comes across a fire but he
doesn't have a way to prevent the
Batmobile from being vandalized well
Batman stop trying to tie red hoods legs
already isn't there another way to take
him down that doesn't involve lassoing
him which he's shown to be able to
escape time and again did that knife
just go through concrete help Jason so
he wore a mask under a mask that doesn't
seem practical also was this supposed to
be a reveal because Batman has figured
out on at least three different
occasions in this movie that the little
Robin Hood was Jason Tom why would he
have his hood set with explosives
especially considering he had the
trigger on him at all times what bothers
you more that your greatest failure has
returned from the grave or that I've
become a better Batman than you
rumor has it Christian Bale had the same
conversation with George Clooney Jesus
Christ man so many characters have
crashed through windows in this movie
that it deserves a bonus round but we
just got done with a window bonus round
and I'm worried about repeating myself
also seen does not contain a lapdance we
know that they both got in here through
the window but where exactly is the door
to this bathroom is the window the only
entry I guess what you gotta go you
gotta go
all I've ever wanted to do is kill him
but if I do that if I allow myself to go
down into that place I'll never come
back yeah sure whatever I think it's
more about DC killing Batman's best
villain than it is your deep dark place
that you can never come back for why I'm
not talking about killing penguin or
scarecrow or dent they've killed a lot
of people as well but you know semantics
if you will kill this psychotic piece of
filth I will Jason actually thinks that
Batman has no other option than to kill
him to stop him from killing Joker
Batman suit is filled with so many
deterrence and Jason knows this that
it's silly he thinks this will go down
the way he planned it I have a countdown
and not just have them explode
immediately why does everyone give these
fun guys so many opportunities to escape
the fact that Joker is still alive after
being right next to the explosives and
also pinned down perfectly by pieces of
the building it leveled is so much
convenience that 7-eleven wants to stock
it on the shelves Nightwing remember me
it looked like I was gonna be a part of
this movie there for a second at the
beginning and then I sprained an ankle
and wasn't anymore good times this
doesn't change anything it doesn't
change anything at all well good thing
we spent an entire movie on it then
[Music]
let me tell you what Melvin's toast is
packing right here I've got 411 posi
tract outback 750 double pumper
Edelbrock intake scored over 30 11 to 1
pop-up pistons turbo jet 390 horsepower
we're talking somewhat hey man I know
you got this thing out of a comic book I
want this man dead I want him dead
I want his family dead I want his house
burnt to the ground I want to go to the
middle not gonna build a do you know who
you're messing with your new friends are
dead
we're sending your boss a message this
ends tonight I love it you managed to
find a way to win well the shots came
from the rooftop a sniper holy known
unknown flying objects
I told you not to put metal in the
science oh don't you do that for
different than dick in so many ways yes
it's true this man has no dick